leadership has nothing to do with rank
right i know many people who sit at the
highest levels of organizations who are
not leaders
we do as they tell us because they have
authority over us but we would never
choose to follow them
and yet i know many people with no
formal rank and no formal authority
who've made the choice to look after the
person to the left of them and made the
choice to look after the person to the
right of them and we would follow them
anywhere
we call you leader not because you're at
the top we call you leader
because you went first because you took
the risk to head towards the danger
you took the risk to express uncertainty
you took the risk
to ask for help that's why you earn
the rank of leader because you literally
led by the behavior you led by example
when this person says my leader is not
taking care of our team
i get that the question is who's taking
care of the team
you can be the leader you wish you had
it does not require rank or authority to
pick up the phone and say how are you
and it can come from anywhere inside the
organization where one person
may take responsibility to take care of
the mental health of everybody
congratulations you are a leader
what's also fundamental is that whoever
that person is
must remember to act with others in
other words don't just make this
unilateral
decision that i'm going to just go take
care of everybody because my leader
isn't effective blah blah blah blah blah
one talk to colleagues and say hey i
think what i need to do i think our team
is struggling
i think i'm going to reach out to
everybody make sure someone knows what
you're doing
leadership is a team sport because
things will go wrong
things will get difficult some people
may not appreciate it
you've got to have somebody that you can
call them and be like uh what do i do
also don't assume the leader is
ineffective use the same empathy that we
expect down the chain of command up the
chain of command
maybe my leader is stuck maybe my leader
is confused
maybe maybe my leader is stressed out of
their mind maybe my leader is dealing
with trauma
we have no idea what's going on in that
person's private life
maybe my leaders got marital issues or
struggling with their kids like
we don't know and so sometimes
part of that check-in is to call our
boss and hey boss you were really hard
on us
on the zoom call the other day i just
wanted to see are you okay
and giving a leader a safe space might
be everything and also
don't expect that you're going to get
the reaction you want immediately some
people are reactors
some people need time to think and to
process before they
before they react so we can't expect
people to react the way we would react
um and so and so if somebody now
now let's take the other scenario which
is there actually is a leader who is
completely ineffective
and this is why i talk about telling
people what you're doing i'm going to
chicken on everybody
because you could ruffle the feathers of
a big ego
right you could ruffle the feathers of
someone who's insecure
and so it could come down on you this is
the risk of leadership
remember read it leadership comes with
risk
which is if you're willing to stick your
neck out even if it's to take care of
your folks
it can sometimes backfire and hurt the
question is it worth
is it worth it and for most people who
want to be a leader that risk is worth
it
this is why we so admire leaders who put
their careers on the line to do the
right thing
because they were willing to risk it and
so you could risk getting in trouble you
could risk getting yelled at
you could risk being told stop doing my
job all true
and if you're alone in that you're going
to have to bear that stress if some
other people know what you're doing
you'll find comfort and security and
confidence
just knowing that there are other people
have your back as well so
make sure you got a leadership buddy
leadership is a team sport you would
never go scuba diving by yourself it's
too dangerous
don't be trying to be a leader by
yourself too dangerous too difficult
um and i and like i said sometimes
leading up
is is what's necessary you could we can
actually help our leaders be better
leaders
because we're going to demonstrate the
behavior we're going to express empathy
we're going to see how they are
we're going to support them hey boss i
got your back whatever you need i'm here
if you want to vent i'm here
and give them a safe space also it goes
up and down
[Music]
you